beer me what's that hand me that water I
always say beer me gets a laugh like a
quarter of the time
so how's what's-her-name you knew her
name
who Karen yeah she's only want to mail
his friends hmm how's the apartment
hanging it's fine
he's check out this sunshine man global
warming right today was supposed to be
really cold I bet what about music
give me music ah yeah she said so
Renekton to give me the beat boys and
free my soul I wanna get lost in your
rock and roll and drift away hey really
did to do but didn't ever give me a beat
boys and free my little oh so don't
think more like a CD here a CD your call
did my girlfriend made an awesome mix
beer me that disc Lauren beer me
strength
Oh
[Music]
now Jim is going to be the client Dwight
you're going to have to sell to him
without being aggressive hostile or
difficult let's go all right fine hmm
ring ring hello hello this is Dwight
Schrute from the Dunder Mifflin paper
company well that's great because I need
paper excellent then you are in luck
because we are having a limited time
offer only on everything wow this is my
lucky day what is your name sir I am
bill but liquor really that's your real
name how dare you my family built this
country by the way you're respectful to
him please yes Michael did you hold on
one second that's my other wine what no
but I hello yeah no I'm just thought
about this stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just gonna keep him on the line
forever and not buy anything okay it's
up to you to change mine sorry that was
a family emergency oh no what's wrong
you know what that's private boundaries
Dwight oh I'm sorry mr. buttlicker as I
was saying so we're having a limit of a
little bit louder I'm hard of hearing
it's hard if he's an old man okay as I
was saying right now we're a talk louder
okay
our prices have never been lower when
you have to talk loud never been lower
louder son but liquor our prices have
never been lower stop hey that is
totally inappropriate
she's never yell at the guy no you
listen to me sir here we go
the three words I would describe you as
is aggressive yes hostile and definitely
difficult please mister by my right
right you know the phone can give me the
phone mr. buttlicker me the phone
I have to put on with my boss so I
should hope so who is this hello this is
Michael Scott regional manager well this
is William M buttlicker
hello mr. buttlicker how may we help you
Michael I like the sound of your voice
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna buy one
million dollars worth of paper products
today yeah that's done thank you very
much sir I don't think you'll regret it
did he or the mask there is one
condition Michael yes you have to fire
the salesman that treated me so terribly
don't do it Michael
who are you faxing so early in the
morning Oh Anna who explained I don't
have a ton of contact with his Granton
branch but before I left I took a box of
Dwight's stationery so from time to time
I send Dwight faxes from himself from
the future
Dwight at 8 a.m. today someone poisons
the coffee
do not drink the coffee more
instructions will follow cordially
future Dwight don't thank me later
question what kind of bear is best
that's a ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets bears beets
battlestar galactica bears do not what
is going on what are you doing last week
I was in a drugstore and I saw these
glasses $4 and it only cost me $7 to
recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollars
you know what imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery so I thank you
any theft is not a joke Jim millions of
families suffer every year Michael oh
that's funny
Michael hmm okay hold on hold on judges
in session what is the problem here put
my stuff in jello again that's real
professional Thanks third time it wasn't
funny the first times either
and if he never comes back again that's
okay
we're friends and I'm sure we'll stay
friends we just we never got the timing
right you know I shot him down and then
he did this name to me and
but you know what it's okay I am totally
fine
everything is gonna be totally sorry are
you free for dinner tonight yes
all right then it's a date ah Dwight
we're so close just buy us a few more
minutes well they just called me in for
an update so I'll call you right back
okay okay great
hey Dwight sending the subs
you ready hmm you kidding I was born
ready
I don't know how to tell you this but we
have a little bit of a problem know what
the minister just told me that it's
tradition for the bestisch mensch to be
older than the groom oh come on I've
never heard of such a I haven't heard of
it obviously but I'm out because I'm
significantly other than you not
significant is a big word I think here
well okay either way easier way
Dwight I can't be there for you I'm
sorry Jim I just really wish there was
something I could do
like
I can't believe you came that's prank
ever
Wow you look terrible so beautiful my
veil talk I knew when we were getting
married and I'm five months pregnant
that I'm not gonna be able to wear the
dress that I always wanted or high heels
you look just as I imagined you BAM
you're so pretty thank you who cares
just stupid veil I know this is the one
thing I was supposed to be able to
control was a fail there now we're even
you